Very last hour!
Channel releases 1 new slow mo choreography,
song with which he represented
Spain in 2022 on the stage of Eurovision 2004.
Stay until the end of the video
because I'm going to show you what this great moment has been like.
Follow me so you don't miss the Eurovision news
because in a very short time
I will be in Malmo telling you absolutely everything.
For those of you who don't know,
Chanel,
our representative at Eurovision 2 022,
will perform at Eurovision 2 024
and it will do nothing more and nothing less
than in the first semifinal,
that is, tomorrow,
because tomorrow,
May 7,
will be the first semifinal of Eurovision 2 024
and you can follow it on TV 2
Spanish at 9:00 p.m.
Chanel had 1 of thes and has rehearsed the song
slow mo,
but with a different choreography.
And you may wonder what the choreography is?
Well, here it is.
What do you think?
Leave it for me in the comments!
Haha
Song
haha